what's going on guys this is Rob if you
guys enjoy my content make sure you hit
the subscribe button and make sure you
hit that little bell so you never miss
out on my sexy voice
okay so I want to be dangerous in for
the next week I want to try an
experiment for the next week I've
actually been thinking about doing this
for a little while and I'm in trying to
find a way to see if we can make it work
so what we're gonna do for this for this
whole week is we're gonna cover the
event of fear itself and this is gonna
be like a background series of videos in
addition to the videos that we normally
do the exception of course is today
because it's Sunday and so normally we
would cover X where we should be
covering x-men in green Green Lantern
but I've been getting a house remodeled
and all kinds of good stuff and that
went on the back burner and I'm gonna do
this instead so I'm kind of curious to
see how people will respond to this now
fear itself is an interesting story
here's a funny thing about this so when
Marvel when Joe Quesada took over Marvel
Marvel Comics in the early 2000s as
editor-in-chief basically from 2000
going forward it was designed like we
work everything right and then we went
into siege and then we had like Dark
Reign siege the heroic age and then we
go into fear itself and the heroic age
was designed to basically say here's
heroes being heroes initially it was
like that like all these different
characters and teams got one shots and
then you had like the actual heroic age
miniseries and so on and so forth but it
didn't last all that long because in
reality people are kind of like the
darker tone of storytelling like stories
like Civil War Secret Invasion things
like that people somewhat enjoyed that
the other half of this was that by the
time 2011 and 2012 came around Marvel
was planning out Secret Wars and so the
result was that Jonathan Hickman's fan
I'm sorry Jonathan dikmen's Avengers the
New Avengers picked up shortly after
this and then just started going forward
with the collapse of the multiverse so
there wasn't really a whole lot of time
to sort of restore heroes back to what
they're supposed to be quote-unquote
instead it was just kind of picking up
sticking with what worked and then
eventually going into Secret Wars which
led into all-new all-different marvel
now initially what this does is this
picks up with the character of sin now
Cynthia Smith is the daughter of Red
Skull and her character originally
appeared back in Captain America comics
and issue number 290 we're really 289
going into 290 but she was basically
this this idea that Red Skull wanted an
air for himself and so with this in mind
what ended up happening here is that
Cynthia Schmidt was basically
brainwashed more or less now the
original intention of Red Skull was to
kill her
because she wasn't a boy but ultimately
her life was spared and he started
raising her to become his new protege
now this comes after Andrew Baker's
Captain America run and the reason why I
say that the reason why matters is
because during that
run that included basically the
conclusion of civil war the events that
went into the death of Captain America
the return of Bucky Barnes Red Skull
having a Cosmic Cube different things
like that but ultimately resulted in
quote-unquote Red Skull dying
and so Cynthia Schmitt it was really
kind of her chance to shine and it was a
way to bring her in and have her go
forward as a potential replacement for
the Red Skull which of course as we know
it didn't work that's one of the things
you read comics long enough you the one
of the things you learn is that nothing
ever stays changed forever
and so in this instance what she's done
is she's allied herself with Baron Zemo
now what they've done is they've
discovered the book of the skull and the
book of the skull basically housed
various secrets that Red Skull kept
hidden and various sources of power that
he was never able to use for one reason
or another now this ultimately leads
into them basically accessing the bunker
of of Red Skull and then once they get
in Cynthia Schmidt begins to basically
sort of reveal this tale and what we end
up finding out is that in not in the
1940s during during World War two that
the Red Skull had essentially traveled
to a section of Atlanta really in
Germany but had brought Atlantean
mystics to him and in turn basically
forced them to start using their various
forms of magics in order to access a
sort of super weapon out there that
would serve the purpose of allowing the
Germans to basically win world war two
now the other half of this is the
invaders themselves because with this
going on essentially the artifact has
been summoned more or less by Red Skull
has flowed across the sky and landed
somewhere else we knew they'd have to go
chase it down now this ultimately leads
to to them basically accessing where the
Red Skull was operating out of just
because of the fact of word had reached
their ears as strange things were going
on and the invaders were literally
jumping from light you basically
following the trail of the Germans and
liberating all the camp so they could
come across and so when neighbor war
steps in here and is up finding out that
all the members of other you know these
various lanten's have essentially all
been killed it's a big to-do because one
of the things to remember is that when
it comes to name work he is fiercely
protective of his people as Prince is
basically the ruler of Atlantis he'll go
to the ends of the earth now from here
picking up with Red Skull as well as the
rest of these German forces once they
arrive here you've also got the you got
the invaders hot on the trail because by
this point the various folks in Germany
had basically said hey look here's what
was going on with the Red Skull and
various magics and so on and so forth
but this item had basically crash-landed
in a crash landed in Antarctica and the
initial indication is that it's a hammer
because Red Skull cannot pick it up he
can't lift it now this is not the hammer
of Thor this is a
totally secret hammer that no one's ever
known about before and so the result
here is that red skulls response is
basically saying no one can know about
this outside of us basically if you tell
anybody I'll kill you not only that like
build a fortress do whatever you have to
do but your job is to study this thing
and learn how to use its power now the
big takeaway from this is at one this is
indeed a hammer to a red skull basically
lies to von strucker and everybody else
when he says this is explicitly for the
fear and none of you guys are supposed
to know about this thing this is not for
your eyes to see when in reality it was
never moved
it was never lifted because it couldn't
be lifted by Red Skull or anybody else
and so when cynthia finishes telling
this story to a baron zemo
what she ends up doing is basically
saying like this is you know what I have
here is a map a location of where this
hammer is because you know access to
this tomb again only really reveals
information it doesn't actually reveal
any particularly powerful artifacts and
so is Cynthia essentially betrays
summons you know and takes off to find
the hammer for herself and so at this
point we jump forward to the actual fear
itself story so again we're gonna do
this very similar to civil war since
you've got the the tie-ins and you've
got like the main event itself now this
is where fear itself really begins to
give us what it was that Joe Quesada and
company were shooting for in the sense
that like Civil War it was designed to
be a reflection of the of the modern day
now this is in 2010 2011 and so we're
talking about right before the point
when like housing prices after the
mortgage crisis had reached bare bottom
when it was basically like dropped off
to the lowest point and then began the
point of recovery and so what you have
here are a lot of people who are just
angry right I mean that's the nature of
this while this story isn't really
political it is designed to basically
take these political tones from the real
world and feed them into the story right
like he had the mortgage crisis of 2008
Americans almost destroy the economy
Obama told the American people sorry
about your luck they have the banks and
that was the end of that and so with
this whole thing going forward what you
have are people who are in a state of
anger and resentment and who are lashing
out according but the funny thing about
this is that Steve Rogers basically
catches on to the small nuance thing and
essentially says people are more
aggressive than they normally would be
and so where he's kind of looking at all
this the the initial response is
something's wrong things aren't right
here something's going on here this also
leads to the various armed forces tear
gassing protesters because as we know
civil disobedience is still disobedience
and so of course they're basically all
tear gassed and they're they're knocked
out for a time or at the very least
subdued and things kind of returned
state of normalcy now picking back up
with with with Sen and traveling to an
out and Arctica this massive citadel of
sorts has basically been constructed not
only that what she says is that all
these scientists from World War two are
currently occupied inside this place
that they've been stuck here the entire
time and they have no no idea of what's
been going on outside in the real world
they don't know the war is ended they
don't know that Red Skull is basically
dead they don't know any of that stuff
as far as they're aware they're still
operating on orders from the Red Skull
and what they've been doing is studying
this hammer the entire time but in the
end it's all to no avail they haven't
figured out a way to lift it they
haven't figured out a way to tap into
its power it's just a thing that's there
and they're basically doing the same
thing day in and day out and so what
ends up happening here is that sin
basically approaches the hammer picks it
up and immediately switches over she
basically starts calling herself Scotty
now the reason why is because that's the
actual inscription on the hammer itself
it's basically that hammers name and so
where she Dawn's this hammer
she begins going forward saying we're
going to seek out it's you know
basically its father is owner and then
go from there now at this point this is
when we start to switch over into iron
man basically rebuilding Asgard and is
actually a pretty cool thing because
remember this comes after the events of
siege which come after the events of
Dark Reign so Norman Osborn has already
been two popes right he's already been
toppled been defeated and dark reign is
over he's no longer in in control of
shield but for the most part the the
purpose of Dark Reign and even the
events of siege was the basically
disband and to remove the entirety of
the superhuman Registration Act that was
basically a holdover from the events of
Civil War essentially it was the Marvel
Comics equivalent of somebody just sort
of letting their voice trail off it
would just kind of be something that was
never really referenced anymore kind of
forgotten and fans would eventually ask
the question what happened to the
Registration Act and what we wouldn't
want to have to release a one-shot or go
through a whole bunch of Hoops in order
to provide an answer to that question
and so in this instance what is up
happening here is is with the
Registration Act gone
Captain America Steve Rogers is long
since back he's been reborn after the
events of his of his death and this
basically leads into iron man chipping
up and essentially saying while this
does seem kind of weird at the end of
the day it is people acting aggressively
that's really all it is because all
these tests are being done to ask the
question is it some kind of external
factor is there some psychic mutant out
there that's going crazy and using their
powers is it some villain to Mysterio
make it all happen and there's there's
no answer to that it's not the actions
of any one person that pushed these
people to the extreme it's just that
they're just
really that pissed off and so the
responsive iron man basically looking at
Captain America is saying after world
war two was over and what did you guys
do you guys built things you had the
economic explosion of the United States
of the 1950s and so his response is to
say we need to do the same thing you
have people right now who basically feel
like they were ripped off left hanging
what they need is to be put to work what
they need is to be able to do something
with the auspices that they can make the
world better and so the result is that
iron man says we're gonna get them to
work as guards been destroyed it was
destroyed by the century during siege so
let's build a new one I told them I
would so let's just start you know let's
get to work on building a new Asgard and
that's what everybody starts to do now
this is kind of a background thing
instead it's basically iron man getting
out there and telling the world here's
what we're gonna do we're gonna rebuild
the entirety of Asgard now the reason
why this matters is that for those of
you guys who are reading Thor comics
right now what you'll notice is that
there's two Asgard's there's basically
old Asgard which also exists in the
dimension of Asgard then there's
Asgardian which is hovering out there
around Saturn somewhere the one that's
around Saturn that's the one that Iron
Man built and so again with with Scotty
traveling down to where this particular
beam is located at she basically starts
facing off against all these various
monsters and demons that have been
placed there by Odin is kind of a
measure of protection now when it comes
to Asgardian magic it gives a little
iffy it's really a plot device more than
anything else
Captain America might be able to
overcome Asgardian magic in one story
and then he's just hopelessly powerful
powerless against it in another story in
this instance these kind of beasts and
monsters being placed here we would have
to believe our most likely beings that
none of the superheroes would be able to
successfully defeat on their own and so
that's why Scotty's here is because
she's going through and literally
tearing them limb from limb Lee using
this hammer ripping them apart only to
find out there's basically a kind of
sarcophagus with a seal of sorts on it
and when she penetrates this seal and
enters into the inside and this sort of
you know tomb more or less she's met by
the arrival of a guy who refers to
himself as the all-father saying that
like he's the rightful ruler of Asgard
so it was a pretty cool thing because
when that happens
Odin basically says this is it this is
the prophecy that I've been trying to
avoid for all this time this serpent has
finally made his return and so it's
interesting here because when Thor comes
along and basically starts conversing
with his father the two of them start
getting really really aggressive because
Thor's idea is look we should be
standing next to the earthly superheroes
who are looking to try to find a way to
rebuild Asgard for Odin it's really more
pride than anything else and that's
always been the thing about his
character the way that Odin has been
written Marvel Comics has always been
that he's exceedingly prideful in the
sense that he's like a scardy in
business is Asgardian business and we do
not air our dirty laundry but for Thor
he's walking in the middle of the road
he's an Avenger on one side and an
Asgardian on the other and when the punt
when the question was asked earlier
which one would he choose as guardians
or man he chooses man and so the result
here is that he's kind of taken a stance
against Odin now where Thor pops up with
me owner and is just kind of like look
if that's how you want to be then we can
take this to the mattresses and I can be
the hottie with the hammer
it's basically on responding by saying
hammer drop do not allow Thor to lift
you now it's small things like this that
really go towards the idea of Thor
becoming unworthy when Thor first lost
the ability to wield his hammer not only
could Thor not lift it Odin couldn't
lift it the hammer had basically had a
will of its own it was doing its own
thing now of course we know the answer
to that now but at the time it will at
the time we didn't and that was the
nature of the hammer in response to how
the Asgardian mythos function that while
it was the hammer the Thor wheel it it
was it was basically passed on to him by
Odin and the enchantment that Odin place
on it was that only a worthy person
could wield it and so the response that
Odin makes is that he gives and he takes
away and so basically it's one of these
things by the grace of me goes your
ability to wield that hammer and it is a
significant moment because it shows just
how much more powerful Odin is than Thor
regardless what is up happening is Odin
basically says we're departing this
place we don't need humanity's eight
we're leaving this place and we're going
back to Asgard and so again it's
interesting because switching back over
to scotty and with this this guy
basically the serpent her response is if
what you're looking to do is topple the
Asgardians and essentially conquer the
world is this something that can be done
by us and the response he gives is it
will not just be us it's going to be
those who I deem to be worthy and so
what he does is he basically summons a
handful of hammers which are going to
land in different places on earth and
various people are going to pick them up
and they're gonna become the worthy
basically the followers of the serpent
and in turn like be imbued with all new
levels of powers each one representing a
different facet of what the serpent
stands for and so while all this is
going on essentially earth is
is under siege by hidden Asgardian
powers that no one really seemed to be
aware of before outside of Odin and in
the moment when they could use the help
of the Asgardians they leave odin
instructs all of them to walk away and
so they're all basically being taken
back to Asgard Thor himself is being
forced back there and Earth is being
left to the defense of the superheroes
who were there and that's really about
it
but with that being said guys we're
gonna bring this video to an end if you
are new here - comments explained make
sure you guys with the sub button to
become part of the Rob core if you guys
enjoy this video make sure you drop a
like and yeah I will catch you all later
peace
[Music]
you
[Music]